book of mormon uh which is do you know
my second cousin wrote this
or my third cousin oh really this guy
robert lopez who's like kind of related
to me but really not related to me
and him and his wife probably want
nothing to do with me they're new york
uh
theater people theatre people a book of
mormon the tony winning musical
uh comedy by trey parker matt stone and
robert lopez so he's the
he's the music okay he writes the music
he wrote uh let it go
uh for trozen he wrote the music for
frozen he wrote avenue q
um the show's a reverend depiction of
africans has been much discussed topic
in theater circles since matters
of broadway's entrenched racism took on
a renewed scrutiny followed last
summer's blm protest in a people tv
interview
original cast member josh gad asked
about a potential film adaptation said
i don't know that the show could open
today and have the same sort of open arm
response that it did then
it's not to say that it's less
significant or wonderful or incredible
as a musical
i just think the nature of the art to
adapt
isn't it a book about mormons who are
ridiculous yeah
these people believe in magical
underwear and that the bible was
uh dictated to a guy named joseph smith
that was like staying in a holiday inn
or something
yeah so the whole
musical is a brilliant satire about how
insane that is correct to a degree right
and they i guess they also they're
they're slightly tone-deaf when it comes
to africans because it's satirizing
mormons correct
who are probably racist
yeah right yeah that's the whole point
right the whole point is for you to go
look how ridiculous right look how
absurd
not well they got a point right but
that's the fear
the fear is that people go there and
they sit down in a broadway theater in
the middle of manhattan and go
yep they're right they're right about
black people
they're wrong about everything else they
believe about magical underwear and
joseph smith it was like some drunk
who came up with some dumb like they're
they're wrong about all that and the
temple you have to go
yeah they're wrong about all that but so
it's absurd to me this system was the
most successful broadway show
in you know other than hamilton in like
history book of mormon was so
incredibly successful nobody
was upset at book of mormon it was
widely understood
that this was a parody of people that
believed
absurd things okay
and now people are going we have to
adapt correct
we have to change it it's interesting
when you look at trey parker and matt
stone who are probably the most
brilliant satirists
of our time and political social
commentary nobody really does it better
and people going let's change it let's
take a step
back and let's change it
and i don't know it just seems like it
it's never-ending
and then in the heights comes out
lin-manuel miranda people go well
there's colorism
uh the latin people are not afro-latino
i don't know
listen you know
at the end of the day it's like
it's a great quote we're letting the
perfect become the enemy of the good
if it is good to have more
representation which i think it is
it's clearly good as long as it's based
on talent right
merit and finding people that are really
good at what they do
and not softening uh the entire space to
where you're elevating mediocre people
based solely on uh
you know box checking but if if if you
have people that are super
talented which in many cases they do
this is a great positive thing but let's
not let the perfect become the enemy of
the good
nothing's going to be and it's it's also
whose idea is perfect we don't know what
perfect
is but certain people's idea of like
everything has to check every box and be
the most
and it's like we're losing art can't
function like that
it can't it just simply cannot and all
the people that dismiss these concerns
and go like this is all old people that
are like hey i
i can't go on stage and hate transgender
people anymore
sure there's an element of that but i
think the more
you know reasonable people are saying
all these things are a net positive
diversity
different voices different stories
things like that
it matters how it's done and it matters
that the art is first the comedy's first
whatever you're doing happens to be
first and
you're not pathologizing everything
into a political statement you're making
something great and including other
people
for no other reason than the fact that
they enrich the the work and make it
better
it's crazy that essential never had an
asian person on
it's crazy that they didn't have a black
woman i've said that black women are
probably the naturally funniest group of
people
over a certain age usually over 40. but
it's crazy that essential but it's all
these white
liberal uh you know harvard guys that
all you people want to be ruled by all
the time
all you people they seem to escape as
long as you're a tall
ivy league white guy you seem to get out
of the you seem to have that and they
everybody still you know builds a statue
to you on the temple mount
um i don't cast snl you know they
probably had some blind spots
they certainly did but you know we've
taken it to a level here where it's
you know where it's getting absurd
you know you know if every single story
just has to have the most the most
marginalized people
truly are dead people
right they're not alive they don't have
the privilege of
even drawing breath so if we take this
to its logical conclusion
we're all necrophiliacs because if
you're alive there's some level of
privilege in being alive
so if we're just gonna do if we're just
going to have
we're just gonna we're gonna have to put
a bunch of corpses in a room
and call it the christmas story
if if that's what we're really gonna do
because now people are like well you
have you're ableist you can walk
you're neurotypical you're not autistic
you're cisgendered so you're the gender
that you were born as
you're straight you're not queer
you're you know so so again we just
we're going down the line here
and it just seems a little ridiculous
and and we all know that and there's
really no way out of it per se
so that's why there'll probably be some
type of
uh there's a split happening and it's
pretty big
the people that are on tv right now that
have their own shows have far less
followers on twitter and instagram than
i do and other people that are online
one of the reasons for that is the
eyeballs are leaving tv and they're
going to the internet
how do people try to colonize the
internet what a word
colonize we don't know but
it's coming it's coming
and you see the split and the people
that are on one side of the split are in
a fit of rage
i don't care i can enjoy shows like
hacks on hbo
i'd say they're fun shows but
a lot of the same people in that part of
the entertainment business
are somehow angry that there's people
online
that have money and then have a
following uh
and the people in the media that work
for
major corporations and networks are
angry that there are people that are on
sub stack
writing and having a following so you
see a theme here
you see this decentralization happening
and a lot of people are
not happy about it there's a lot of
people that are angry about it
and they're going to do something they
keep
trying to do something the problem is
the money is with us for the moment the
the
people want the content we have the
freedom right now
and it's making money because it
resonates with people because we can do
what within reason what we want to do
and we hope it stays like that
you know but if not i will with hunter
biden
start a podcast and it will be great
no more he's he's a lot of great takes
it's just too much of a get off my lawn
energy like a lot of his takes are good
it's just
couched in a and again it's my same
thing it's like
him kimmel fallon colbert just go
yeah yeah just go you've been around for
too long you did it you had it
we we have the same these these networks
are terrified of replacing these people
they try to literally sing it bombed
they try they're
they're terrified they're terrified of
what
the new late-night shows will look like
because of everything i just mentioned
but give me one
give shane gillis one give nick mullen
wouldn't it be great
wouldn't it be great you want to see
that guy that writer uh
sesame seeds head melt
i get a late night show shane gillis
gets one and nick mullen gets one
you wanna see like just heads
his head just completely melts